-Fred, we just went through,
you and I, 19 months apart.
And it used to be that I would
see you all the time.
And pretty much every day,
I would know what you were
doing, even the boring stuff,
and I got to be honest,
Fred, I missed that.
And I'm also aware that you have
a photographic memory
and an incredible ability to
remember the mundane details
of every day of your life.
-Yeah, I do.
-So to make up for lost time,
I thought it'd be fun if
I would just pick a random day
from the last year and a half
and you would tell me
what you did on
Thursday, May 7, 2020.
-Oh, Thursday, May 7, 2020.
So that would be --
That was a Tuesday.
May 7th was a Tuesday,
not a Thursday.
-Okay.
-And that was
my...doctor's birthday.
So I remember
I had just seen him.
I had an appointment
like the week before.
And then I was like,
"Oh, it's his birthday."
So I made another appointment,
you know, just to, like,
surprise him and say like,
"Happy birthday."
So --
-So, when you call him to make
the second appointment,
do you have to say that
something is wrong?
Because, obviously,
you just had a check-up,
so there's not really
a reason to go back.
-Yeah, so, I say like,
"I got to see you."
And, so, I was
like, "I got to see you."
And then I go.
And, so, then I was like,
"I'm gonna get a cake."
So I bought a cake that day.
This was like 10:15 a.m.
-Is when you bought the cake?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-So, I got a strawberry cake,
only icing.
-So, what does a cake that's
only icing even look like?
-Seth...
You know,
it's, like, layers of icing.
-Okay.
-So, I go in.
I've got a $100 bill.
-Wait. Is a $100 bill
to give the doctor
or to pay for the cake?
-No, no, it's to give the doctor
as like a "happy birthday."
I go in, and he's --
-Put it in a card?
-Put it in a card.
-What did the card say?
-It said, "Hey...
I have a photographic memory,
so I remembered
that it's your birthday.
So here's 100 bucks.
Do whatever you want with it."
-That's said that
on the front of the card?
-I wrote it on
the front of the card.
-Okay, gotcha.
-So, I go in,
and he's like, "What's wrong?"
And I'm like...
I was like, "What's wrong is,
it's your birthday."
So, I gave him the cake,
and he's like,
"You know, you can't do this.
I have, like, patients.
There's, like -- There are
medical emergencies out there."
I was like, "I know.
I'm leaving.
Happy birthday."
-Oh, man, so it didn't end well.
-Oh, no, no. He smiled.
-Okay.
-Because -- Oh,
yeah, he wasn't admonishing.
He wasn't like this.
He was more like...
You know?
So, I just, like, waved "hi"
to everyone in the waiting room
and I just left.
-So, these are people with
serious medical illnesses.
You walk out
and you sort of wave to them?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Okay.
-But I couldn't see their
expression because of the masks.
-So there's a chance they
were really happy to see you.
-Yeah, I'm assuming
that they were really happy.
So, then I went and got
a couple of sandwiches
at this Italian place.
-Okay, why two?
-For dinner.
So I got a lunch one
and a dinner one.
-Do you often do that?
Do you often get your lunch and
dinner at the same time?
-Yes.
-Okay.
-So, then I had them both
and then drove home,
parked my car,
watched some cartoons.
-Oh, interesting.
-To fall asleep before what
would have been my dinner.
-Okay.
-So I did a quick nap,
maybe two hours.
-Uh-huh.
-And just sort of got up,
and then it was bedtime,
so I was like, "Okay,
well, that's my whole day."
-Wow.
-And I skipped dinner,
and that was -- Yeah --
-That's amazing.
-Yeah.
-Thank you so much for that,
Fred.
-Blue shirt, white pants,
baseball hat,
and then,
at the end of the day, shorts.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-Over the white pants
or instead of?
-Over the white pants.